the world under lockdown in normally
bustling nude alley birds sing out and
deserted streets there is no one at
Greece's tourist hotspots only prayer
echoes across rillette people are
staying home but if we look up nearly
eight billion of us can share in
something else a super moon is above us
rising on Tuesday evening it is expected
to be the brightest and biggest of the
year in China restrictions have eased
and a reduction in pollution means life
is looking up it's really hard to see a
moon this big in Beijing it's been my
first time seeing one the epidemic
situation in China is getting better and
better this represents something good
especially when the super moon shows up
a super moon is a full moon that is
closer to Earth than usual to us it will
look about 30% brighter and 14% bigger
than normal the event happens roughly
every 14 months some astronomers expects
the moon to come closer to Earth than at
any time since 1948
whether you're hunkered down in your
home in central England or you're
hunkered down in your home in suburban
Washington DC or in you know Southeast
Asia you'll be able to see ultimately
the same moon it's something that we can
share globally and we know right now at
this point in time having something that
connects us all I think is really
important and at 360,000 kilometres away
the man in the moon is keeping a good
social distance Charlotte Bellis oj0